at first glance the german russian
museum in kharshorst might seem an
unremarkable building
yet within its walls are reminders of
its importance in history for this is
where the tyranny of nazi germany was
finally ended
when its most senior soldiers
surrendered to their counterparts from
the ussr
tens of millions of soviet citizens had
been murdered in adolf hitler's war of
annihilation
and so this was a victorious moment of
unity for russians and ukrainians
yet 77 years on those two peoples are
again at war
with each other and for the director of
this museum vladimir putin's military
actions in ukraine now have persuaded
him to remove the reference to russia in
his museum's name
the propaganda in in russia is focusing
on all the the naming in the world war
ii and talking about fascists in in
ukrainia which is a lie
so our job will
be to to make clear what really happened
in history in world war ii
in the decades that followed generations
of germans were told of the sins of the
nazis
and thus the feeling seemed to take hold
don't antagonize russia
rather do deals with it draw it into the
community of nations through trade
above all give no country weapons with
which to fight russia
it's a policy the present-day ukrainian
president has repeatedly called on
germany to
the renounce here and every time we talk
to germany we remind them that we have
war and they have something they don't
need which we need a lot
many here share that view they feel
germany should be helping the kiev
government much more and now finally so
too does their chancellor
[Applause]
i respect anyone's pacifism i respect
any attitude but it must seem cynical to
a citizen of ukraine to be told to fight
back against putin's aggression without
weapons this is something that is out of
date now
with weapons like these millions of
russians and ukrainians fought and died
to defeat the nazis
what might those soldiers have thought
then to learn that one day their two
countries would be at war with each
other
in 1945 many in the free world saw the
russian soldier as a friend and
liberator
far fewer do so now
dominic kane al jazeera at the soviet
war memorial in berlin
let's go live to nadeem baba in london
for us nadeem so what's been happening
across europe to mark this anniversary
particularly in the context of russia's
invasion of ukraine
well folly it certainly has been marked
it's not a particularly important
anniversary the 77th anniversary but
given the conflict in ukraine it's off
it's on everybody's minds rather
for example the uk has just announced
1.6 billion dollars worth of extra
military support to ukraine in paris the
newly uh re-inaugurated president
emmanuel macron
laid a wreath at the tomb of the unknown
soldier by the actor triumph in paris it
was not a huge event but very symbolic
and notably his foreign minister
jean-yves ledrion has referred to the
conflict in relation to world war ii he
says we won't forget the soldiers from
across the soviet union including uh
ukrainians and russians who contributed
to the victory over nazi germany but he
went on on twitter to say we reject all
forms of instrumentalization and
manipulation of the memory of those who
gave their lives well it's probably too
late for that because you've heard in
victoria's report how president zolensky
of ukraine has directly accused the
russians of reenacting the horrors of
nazism in ukraine right now and
similarly there has been rhetoric from
the russians since they uh launched the
invasion in february that they were
trying to denazify the state the country
of ukraine something that most
ukrainians have rejected as ridiculous
the russians themselves are rehearsing
for their commemorations on monday a
victory day
um remembering all of the millions of
soviet citizens who died during what
they call the great patriotic war there
have been tanks with photos of russian
soldiers who have died in the last few
weeks in ukraine a direct link there
it's not clear ukraine has accused
russia of preparing for mobilization and
a declaration of a full war in ukraine
the kremlin is rubbishing that
alternatively they might try to present
what they've gained so far in the east
and the south as a victory getting the
russian population used to the idea of
an ongoing conflict nadim thank you for
that nadine baba live in london